do you want to hear something kind of
hilarious in the US Nintendo has sold
more copies of Zelda breath of the wild
on the switch then actual units of the
new console I'm Matt and this gamespot
news update is all about Zelda and the
switch Nintendo has announced that the
switch sold more than nine hundred and
six thousand units in the US during
March the company also reiterated that
it's the fastest selling console in
Nintendo's history on top of that the
legend of zelda breath of the wild has
sold 1.3 million copies with more than
nine hundred and twenty-five thousand of
those being on the switch yep the
switches most popular game is a better
seller than the actual console Nintendo
believes the reason for this is people
buying a limited edition of the game to
collect and a second version to play me
however I think it's partly because it's
easier to get your hands on the game
that it is the switch Nintendo's even
acknowledge that its shipments haven't
been able to keep up with the high
demand that sounds pretty likely to me
Nintendo also announced that breath of
the wild is the fastest selling Zelda
title across the series entire 30 year
history and looking at our review it
seems like it's deserving of that
gamespot's peter brown scored it a 10
out of 10 and called it the most
impressive game nintendo has ever
created on top of that we produce a
bunch of Zelda videos and you can keep
up on all of them by hitting those like
and subscribe buttons actually if you
want to see something really cool then
check out our video in which we put on a
blindfold and play breath of the wild